c'est un second coup dur pour certains
commerçants à nouveau forcé de fermer
pour frédéric sucre qui avait déjà dû
retarder l'ouverture de son magasin de
course à pied en jouant à cause du
premier confinement la sentence est
difficile à accepter
certes avec un assouplissement mais
encore une fois les commerces en
pâtissent c'est compliqué c'est
difficile c'est l'incertitude
alors ya un dicton qui dit entreprendre
c'est apprendre à oublier ses certitudes
et vivre l'expérience de l'incertitude
et bien je peux vous dire que la clé
l'expérience de la certitude sur une
trame de vue-là forget ayant reçu leur
dernier client en magasin ce jeudi 29
octobre les commerces non essentiels
cherche des solutions pour s'adapter
rapidement
effectivement je vais toujours devoir
trouver des alternatives proposées aux
clients des rendez vous
privatif proposé peut-être des
livraisons à domicile
je suis en train d'y réfléchir et tout
ça effectivement j'ai de voir le mettre
en place très rapidement mais qui nous
dit qu'il n'y aura pas une troisième
vague qui arrivera en janvier ou en
février qu'on va devoir de nouveau fermé
donc c'est ce manque de perspective qui
est compliqué et difficile à vivre
d'autant que les aides apportées par
l'état lors du premier confinement
n'étaient pas jugées suffisantes par les
entrepreneurs
on a eu 1500 euros pour deux mois de
fermeture avec deux salaires de gérante
donc oui j'ai confiance qu'on puisse pas
aider tout le monde mais
c'est trop bas pour pouvoir aider une
entreprise à sion démons on va on va
voir on va mettre une stratégie en place
on va faire ce qu'il faut pour pour
survivre survivre
c'est donc le mot d'ordre pour les
petits commerçants yvelinois qui avance
une fois de plus à l'aveuglé